>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> And gentlemen, please
welcome the Librarian
of Congress, Dr. James
H. Billington.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington:
Thank you very much.
We are honored this evening on the
occasion of the first presentation
of the Kluge Prize for lifetime
achievement in the human sciences
to have a number of
distinguished guests.
I'd like to first of all recognize
and thank Her Royal Highness,
Victoria, the Crown Princess of
Sweden is with us for this occasion.
Ambassador Jan Eliasson, Mrs.
Kerstin Eliasson of Sweden.
They represent the country in which
the Nobel awards are being conferred
in this very season
and their guidance
and help has been instrumental
in perfecting, we hope,
this procedures for this prize.
I'd also like to mention and thank
Mr. Bronislaw Geremek the charge
d'affaires of the Polish
Embassy for being with us tonight
and I would also pay special thanks
and our gratitude to John Kluge
who is the benefactor of not
only this but of a wide variety
of fellowships to bring
scholarship into this city who has,
with his characteristic modesty,
asked not to be specially
recognized,
but his name has to mentioned.
[ Applause ]
And I want to pay special
thanks this evening
to the congress of
the United States.
We are, the Library of Congress,
founded at the very time the
congress decided to relocate
in the new capitol
here in Washington.
We have with us tonight
a variety of congressmen
who are either coming
or about to come.
Senators Ted Stevens, Christopher
Dodd, Representatives Vern Ehlers,
Rush Holt, Jack Kingston, Dale
Kildee, John Larson, Jim Leach,
John Mica, Jim Moran,
David Price, Ralph Regula,
Rodney Frelinghuysen,
and Edmond Markey.
The congress has created
and faithfully nurtured
within its own branch this enormous
knowledge and information asset
for the intelligent governance of
the United States and it has chosen
in its wisdom to allow free public
access to our ever-growing body--
to-- of an ever-growing
body of knowledge
to an ever-growing audience here
and virtually through the internet
to keep democracy dynamic.
And especially thank the joint
committee on the library,
which is the oldest joint
committee of the congress,
which is led by its
chairman, Senator Ted Stevens,
the President Pro Tem of the
Senate of the United States
and a distinguished
senator from Alaska.
As vice chairman, Representative
Vern Ehlers of Michigan.
This committee has been of
great importance historically
to the library and it's
an honor to have members
of the committee with us tonight.
Also from our appropriations
committees that make it possible
for this institution to function.
And it is my great pleasure and
distinct honor now to introduce
to you one of the really truly
great supporters of this institution
and its long 203-year history,
the distinguished chairman
of the senate appropriations
committee,
the chairman of the joint committee
on the library, a great friend
of learning, and the
President Pro Tem of the Senate
of the United States, the Honorable
Senator Ted Stevens of Alaska.
[ Applause ]
>> Ted Stevens: Good evening,
friends of the Library of Congress.
I'm very pleased to be
here tonight on behalf
of the United States
Congress for the awarding
of the first John W. Kluge
prize for lifetime achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
And I'm-- of course, I've
already given my congratulations
to Professor Kolakowski
for his high honor.
As chairman of the congress's
joint committee on the library,
it was my privilege to
participate in the capitol ceremony
when John Kluge presented the
Library of Congress an endowment
of $60 million to establish
the Kluge Center.
[ Applause ]
This award is the capstone
of the Kluge Center's mission
to bring the world's leading
thinkers to our Library of Congress.
To use its rich resources
to stimulate scholarship
and interaction with
policymakers in Washington,
thus bridging the scholarly
and policymaking worlds.
I join all of you once more
in thanking our great friend,
John Kluge, for his generous
philanthropy to this library.
Our Librarian of Congress,
Jim Billington,
also deserves our eternal gratitude
for his visionary leadership
of this great institution.
It's nice to be with you.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington: Thank you
very much, Senator Stevens.
We meet tonight in an institution
that arose from the personal library
of the great humanist Thomas
Jefferson in a building that's named
for him and has been gloriously
restored by the congress
of the United States, which created
this institution in the first place.
And we are celebrating in
this ceremony the highest form
of Jefferson's pursuit of
happiness, the pursuit of truth.
This is the essence of
what happens in big ways
and small in any library.
The pursuit of truth, after all,
helps keep us from the
pursuit of each other.
[ Laughter ]
This pursuit has been the
life's work of the first scholar
to be awarded this
unique international prize
in the study of humanity.
And, you know, it's rather
appropriate in the way
that it should be someone from
Poland since people like Brzezinski
and Kosciuszko were part of the
founding fathers, fought in our war
of independence, and
helped bring this country
into being in the first place.
Kluge prize is designed with a high
level of scholarly accomplishment--
and with the high level of
compensation I might add
of the Nobel awards--
and it fills in a gap
between the national sciences that
are so well honored on the one hand
of the Nobel prizes and
peace and literature,
which are recognized in the others.
It is for this lifetime of
achievement in the scholarship
of the human condition that
this award is being made
and it's appropriate, I think,
to make it in America's capital
since so much scholarly work
in these fields has been
done in this country.
First and foremost, the criterion
we established was achievement
of high distinction in
a chosen academic field
as attested to by one's peers.
Additional considerations
were whether--
are whether or not his
or her scholarly work has
also [inaudible] disciplines
in a significant way and, in
some sense, the broader public
of the humanity, which
is the subject of this.
By all three of these, Leszek
Kolakowski emerges as a giant
of the second half
of the 20th century.
In a wide variety of
languages and formats,
he has focused his life
on asking big questions.
He is a gifted and accessible
philosopher, a theoretician
of European culture, a historian
of religion, and an essayist
of enormous sweep, all filled
with the gentle irony and humor
that great humanists
often are able to display.
And last, but by no means least,
he was a major contributor to
and an intellectual inspiration for
the solidarity movement in Poland,
which played such a decisive
role in the peaceful, nonviolent,
and deeply democratic emergence
of Eastern Central Europe
from the totalitarian system
that had been imposed on it
and was long thought by many to
be a permanent system of rule.
The modern world has given birth to
something we call an intelligentsia.
People of learning whose lives are
somehow set apart from the ordinary
and are centered on cultivating
ideas for higher moral purposes.
The word intelligentsia
arouses some suspicion
in the English-speaking world
because it suggests people cut off
from everyday life likely
to promote utopian ideas
that could have disastrous
practical consequences.
But the word intelligentsia
was, in fact, invented by Poles
in the early 19th century after
they had lost their freedom.
And the better anti-utopian version
of an intelligentsia played decisive
role in helping bring freedom back
to Poland in the late 20th century.
Arnold Toynbee and his mighty
12-volume study of history suggested
that large-scale systems of
government continue to prevail
until they meet challenges
to which they cannot
by their very nature find
an adequate response.
The solidarity movement in Poland
was that type of challenge.
It was a mass-based
religiously-grounded bottom-up
nonviolent challenge to a
top-down anti-democratic elite
with an atheistic etiology and
an authority based on fear.
It had no way of adequately
meeting the challenge posed.
The word intelligentsia
in its original Polish
usage was simply taken
from the Latin word for intelligent.
And Leszek Kolakowski embodies that
quality and he spoke more clearly
and more influentially
to the intelligence
of the rising better-educated
generation in Poland
than any other single figure.
He was the voice of hope
that helped free people
from the paralysis of fear.
The chain of events that
down the communist system
in Eastern Europe began in Poland
with a movement inspired both
by religious faith, of which
Kolakowski has made studies as deep
as any European scholar of his time,
and also by straightforward human
enlightened intelligence applied
to inhuman social realities,
which Kolakowski performed
with elegance and significance.
In the words of the-- one of
the great leaders of solidarity,
Bronislaw Geremek, who later
became foreign minister of Poland--
and I'm quoting this, which is,
I think, the right introduction.
We have, incidentally, a formal
citation, which I'm not going
to read, but I think these
words speak eloquently.
He said Leszek Kolakowski's work had
an influence on the course of events
that is difficult to overestimate.
His work achieved that fulfillment
which is the eternal dream
of philosophers and the
ambition of intellectuals.
To influence the fate of the world
and further people's aspirations
of freedom, it accompanied
resistance to repression
and dictatorship in Eastern and
Central Europe at every stage.
This skeptical student
of enlightenment,
this scholar of the
highest intellectual rigor,
this opponent of all
illusions played
that most romantic and
promethean of roles.
He was the awakener of human hopes.
Kolakowski was asked in
an interview recently what
of his many achievements
he was most proud of.
And he said, with his
characteristic modesty,
simplicity of great
philosophers, I'm not proud.
If there is any doubt that the study
of humanity can help do great things
for humanity without
violence and with out--
from one dogmatism to another,
he stands before us tonight.
The man who is not proud, but of
whom we at the Library of Congress--
and I think all of us here--
are very proud and grateful--
have every reason to be,
since we are hailing him
as the first recipient of this
prize in the human sciences
for a lifetime of rare achievement.
We are going to bring out-- in
just a moment, we will present him
with a medal and then
we will be seated
and we will have the world's
premiere of a special salute written
for him by one of the current
senior scholars at the Kluge Center,
the holder of the Papamarkou in
education here at the library,
Miss Libby Larsen, a great
composer from Minnesota,
and this will be the
first time you--
anyone in the world will
have heard this fanfare
that she has written specially
for this occasion and for this man
and it's my pleasure to bring
him out now and to present him
with the first John W. Kluge prize
for lifetime achievement
in the human sciences.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Leszek Kolakowski.
[ Applause ]
You sit down, now.
We speak-- we sit and listen to the
fanfare first, before you speak.
>> Leszek Kolakowski: Oh, I see.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, the
Library of Congress is pleased
to present the world premiere
performance of Fanfare for Humanity,
an original composition by
Libby Larsen commissioned
for the Kluge prize.
Dr. Larsen is the current occupant
of the Harissios Papamarkou chair
in education at the
John W. Kluge Center.
Please now welcome Dr. Libby Larsen.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dr. Leszek Kolakowski.
[ Applause ]
>> Leszek Kolakowski:
The Library of Congress.
Ladies and gentlemen, dear friends,
I couldn't have heard properly
everything what James Billington
said because I was
put in a dark cellar,
but I presume that what he
said was friendly to me.
Now, what is really
extremely difficult
to express the gratitude
towards this extraordinary
distinction properly.
I'm not even sure to whom, except
of course for a few people,
should I express this gratitude
because, well, to James Billington
in the first place, of course he was
the main architect of the system.
Mr. Kluge, who was-- who established
the whole-- the whole thing.
And then mister-- it was Gifford who
had a lot of work, if I understand,
in preparing the whole thing.
But, apart from that, there
were-- as far as I was told--
there were many people who
were active in the process
of selecting this--
reviewing and selecting--
so, I don't know their
names, so-- hardly any.
So, I have to-- I have to
thank them collectively only.
Thank you very, very much.
I--
I repeat-- I repeat what I
already had the opportunity
to say here today.
I learned about the Kluge award
a few months ago when I was--
I got a letter asking me to
nominate a candidate for the award.
Which I did and, unfortunately,
didn't-- I didn't succeed.
This person did not get the award.
All right.
So-- then, however, I knew
nothing about the Kluge Center.
I only-- I learned about
it only quite recently.
And I found it astonishing and
truly a marvelous, great idea,
which will be, I hope, an extremely
helpful instrument to [inaudible]
with a corporation of scholars
from various countries,
various parts of the world,
and, which is new, corporation
and exchange of thought between
scholars and politicians.
Something that is extremely
needed and useful.
I hope it will work.
I think we should all thank James
Billington for this great idea
and I thank him, especially.
Well, then I have to
thank many people,
including, of course, my two girls.
My wife, Tamara, and
my daughter, Agnieszka,
who are always extremely
helpful in whatever I'm doing.
It's not that they're
uncritical, no.
Very often-- very often, they
criticize what I'm doing,
criticize my texts, and more often
than not they are right
in their criticism.
So, I thank both them-- them both.
Now, I would like to
say a few words.
It won't be long, I promise.
And there is something
which has a title--
has a title-- what the past is for.
What the past is for.
So, I start with a few
words about the future.
And this futurology.
According to my definition,
futurology is an extremely serious
science whose subject not only is
nonexistent, but necessarily
nonexistent.
That is to say it-- the future
does not exist and never will,
which is a common-sense remark.
But we have a science about
this nonexistent subject.
Well, perhaps we would
not find this worrying
if it did not immediately bring
to our attention an analogous
but much more terrifying insight.
Mainly that the past
doesn't exist either.
From the time Saint Augustine
and his classic reflections
on the subject, the
mystery of time is absurd
and its tormented nearly
all major philosophers
up to Bergson, Husserl, and Sartre.
The past, by definition, is an
ocean of events that once happened
and this-- and those events are
either retained in our memory
or so that they exist only as
part of our psychological reality
or they are reconstructed by us on
the basis of our present experience
and it is only this
present experience,
our present reconstruction
of the past, that is real.
Not the past as such.
In other words, the entire
[inaudible] of the past exists only,
it seems, as a portion of our-- more
strictly, of my own-- consciousness.
The past in itself is nothing.
This argument can strike
us as a kind of sophistry
or a bizarre philosophical
exercise, but it's not so.
It's not sophistry.
It is serious.
However, we can also look at
the question from another angle.
Everything we see or touch is
obviously a product of events
that had happened once,
perhaps 10 seconds ago,
perhaps 10 million years ago.
It is not-- is it not therefore
proper and reasonable to say
that whoever we see
or touch is the past?
In metaphysical terms, the
past is perhaps nothing; but,
in terms of our direct
experience, the past is everything.
Our entire knowledge of the
so-called external world is nothing
but a continuous, uninterrupted
stream
of acts whereby what was
the past becomes present.
Yes, we may say that far from being
nothing, the past is everything.
And the enigma is time is not
just something philosophers have
constructed to amuse themselves.
We-- when they try to
unravel its mysteries.
No. The mysteries are
accessible to everyone.
And so, of course,
not everyone likes
to spend time in thinking
about time.
It is only philosophers who try to
express this everyday experience.
So, now the digression.
Philosopher is not
there to be liked.
It's not to like them.
I remember a colleague of mine,
a professor of philosophy,
telling me about his six-year-old
son who was the first time
in the school and the teacher asked
all the children to say their names
and then to ask what their father--
what their fathers were doing
and the boy refused to say
anything and the teacher was angry.
And later, at home, he explained
but I couldn't tell them
that my dad is a philosopher because
all the children would laugh at me.
And, indeed, they would
have laughed at him.
But, if the boy had said that his
father was, say, a circus clown,
they would have laughed as well.
Even so, it is a nice, respectable
job to be a circus clown.
Moreover, they would have
laughed if the boy had said
that his dad was a
garbage collector,
even though the profession
of garbage collector is
not only respectable,
but it's one of the most
important in today's world.
Without garbage collectors,
we would not survive for long.
And so, in matters of
philosophy, let us not rely
on the opinions of those kids.
One might add-- one might
add that the profession
of a philosopher has
a significant affinity
with the two professions I've just
mentioned, that of a circus clown
and that of a garbage collector.
But this was a digression.
Let's go back to the
problem of the past.
So, our direct experience may be
plausibly interpreted as a form
of contact with the past, but we can
also speak of knowledge of the past
in a more specific sense, mainly
our knowledge of human history.
And we may ask what this kind
of knowledge of the past is for.
In the tradition of
the enlightenment,
we sometimes find a kind of
disrespect for historical knowledge.
Either because history, more often
than not, is an infinite display
of human stupidity and cruelty
or because nothing profitable can
be learned from what mankind was
up to earlier or else because
history is not a science.
It is indeed arguable that we
cannot use historical knowledge
to help in our present work.
It's not a technical help
we can expect from it.
It may be true.
It may be true that whatever people
know about say military exploits
of Alexander the Great or
Hannibal would not be of much use
in improving the skills of today's
generals and that knowledge,
say of the political intrigues
of the French Royal Court
in the 17th century
would not be of much help
to contemporary politicians.
However, the limited
technical support to be gained
from an acquaintance with the
historical events is not a good
reason for concluding that therefore
historical knowledge is irrelevant
to our life.
We are, of course, the cultural--
though not necessarily physical--
heirs of Alexander the Great,
Hannibal, and French monarchs.
Not to say that their life,
their deeds or misdeeds--
not the reason that they
do not matter to our life.
To say so would be almost as silly
as saying that it would not matter
to me if I were suddenly to erase
from my memory my own past personal
life just because, obviously,
I live in the present,
not in the past.
The history of prior generations is
our history and we need to know it
in order to be aware of our
identity in the same sense
in which my own memory
builds my personal identity.
Makes me a human subject.
So, we learn history in
order to know who we are.
From that assumption that history
is not a science, but rather an art,
it does not follow of
course it is not interesting
or unworthy of being cultivated.
Obviously not.
So, but here's a trivial point.
But saying that history is
not a science may suggest
like that unlike the natural
sciences it simply does not try
to establish general laws,
but is concerned only
with particular events,
unique and unrepeatable.
This question has been
discussed since the 19th century.
It resulted in the well-known
distinction made by Rickert
between nomothetic and
ideographic disciplines.
Between disciplines in which laws
are discovered and disciplines
which are just concerned with the
narration of single occurrences.
In fact, yes, there is no such thing
as the laws of history in the sense
of true and justifiable statements
that would tell us what--
that tell us in what certain
well-defined conditions some certain
well-defined phenomena
necessarily invariably occur.
The belief in laws of history was
a Hegelian or Marxian delusion.
Human history is a collection of
unpredictable accidents and each
of us can easily cite any number
of instances where an event
that was clearly decisive in
shaping the history of mankind
for subsequent decades,
centuries, could have gone
in different way than it did.
There was no-- there
was no necessity
in its happening or in its result.
The phrase the laws of history has
also been used to describe tendency
or trends that are bound to
prevail in the near future.
This use was particularly
frequent in Marxist doctrine
and its ideological meaning calls
that future events could be foreseen
on the allegedly scientific basis.
Alas, all the predictions
made by Marx or later by--
or by later Marxists-- all of
them that were demonstrably false.
So far, development went in an
entirely different direction.
The middle classes, instead of
gradually shrinking and disappearing
as the Marxist prophecy
would have it, grew and grew.
The market, far from being an
obstacle to technological progress,
as Marxists claimed, proved to
be its more powerful stimulus.
The relative and absolute
popularization
of the working class
failed to occur.
The falling rate of profit, which
was supposed to be the cause
of collapse of capitalism
proved vain hope.
The proletarian revolution,
it is revolution resulting
from the conflict between
industrial workers of capitalism.
This revolution never happened.
The Russian revolution was
in a way an example of it.
What perhaps comes-- came-- came
the closest to such a revolution,
at least conceptually-- that was
perhaps the worker's movement
in Poland in the early 80's.
As this movement, it was
directed against a socialist state
and carried under the sign of
cross was the blessing pope.
So much for [inaudible] predictions.
One may say that, in general,
futurology, so-called,
is not unhealthy state and
this for a number of reason.
But there's another important way
in which the nihilistic approach
to history is expressed today.
There is a post-[inaudible]
phrase, also known as postmodernism,
and it says there are no
facts, only interpretations.
This is in-- in the one sense,
it is trivially true and,
in another sense, it is
absurd and dangerous.
It is trivially true that
any description of a fact--
even the simplest-- involves the
entire history of human character.
When I say, for instance, this
morning, on October 29, 2003,
I ate yogurt for breakfast.
My words encompass the entire
history of the European calendar
with all its arbitrariness.
They encompass the concept of
breakfast and the concept of yogurt,
which are all human inventions.
The language I use is a product of
human history and, in this sense,
whenever we use it,
we interpret the word.
The word never shows itself
to us, so to say directly,
so to say stripped and
naked in its purity.
We always perceive it
mediated by our culture,
our history, our language.
But this saying that there are
no facts, only interpretations,
has another and dangerous meaning.
Since historical knowledge
is supposed to consist
in the description of facts,
of things that really happened,
the idea that there are no facts
in the normal sense implies--
this idea implies that
interpretations do not depend
on facts, but the other way around.
The facts are produced
by interpretations.
Let us suppose that I stole
a bottle of wine from a shop.
The saying, Mr. K stole a bottle
of wine would be an interpretation
which generates a fact.
The fact in itself does not exist.
Consequently, phrases like Mr. K is
guilty of stealing a bottle of wine
or Mr. K should be punished
for his crime have no
meaning in relation to a fact.
They are just parts
of the interpretation.
In other words, the
concept of modern judgment
and therefore also the concept
of good and evil are empty.
They don't refer to
an empirical reality,
but only to our way of
judging the reality.
Judging according to an a
priori conceptual [inaudible].
The doctrine that there are no
facts, only interpretations,
in fact, abolishes the idea of human
responsibility and moral judgements.
Moreover, in effect, it considers
any myth, any legend or fable just
as valid in terms of knowledge
as any fact that we have verified
as being verified as such according
to the standards of
historical inquiry.
In epistemological terms, any
mythical theory is just as good
as any historical established fact.
The story of Hercules fighting
against Hydra is not worse,
not less true in historical
terms than the history
of Napoleon being defeated
at Waterloo.
There are not valid rules
for establishing truth,
consequently there is
not such thing as truths.
There is no need to elaborate
on the disastrous cultural
effect of such a theory.
Now, the upfront of my
remarks is, in fact, banal.
Also, the legacy of myths
is certainly an important
and fertile source in human culture.
We must defend and support simply
traditional research methods
elaborated over century-- centuries
and establish the factual cause
of history and separated
from fantasies.
However, narrating those
fantasies might be the doctrine
that there are no facts,
only interpretations,
should be rejected as obscurantist.
And we much perceive-- prevent-- we
must preserve our traditional belief
that the history of mankind--
the history of things
that really happened--
woven of numerable unique
accidents is the history
of each of us human subjects.
Whereas the belief in historical
laws is a figment of imagination.
Historical knowledge, obviously,
is crucial to each of us.
To schoolchildren and students.
To young and old.
We must absorb history as our own,
with all its horrors and tragedies
as well as its beauty and splendor.
It's cruelties and
persecutions as well
as all the magnificent works
of human mind and hand.
We must do this if we are to know
the proper place in our universe.
To know who we are
and how we should act.
One might-- one might ask what the
point of repeating such banalities.
The answer is simply that
it is important to keep
on repeating them again
and again because this--
our banalities we often find
it convenient to forget.
And if we forget them and
if they fall into oblivion,
we'll be condemning our culture--
that's to say our sense--
to ultimate and irrevocable ruin.
That's all I wanted to say.
Thank you very much
for your patience.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.